Last time, in the good Star Trek movie...
Oh no! Khan escaped from his prison?
A new toy called Genesis that creates life in two seconds
but still can't create a good Sonic game in years!
Kirstie Alley as a Vulcan?
She does well, but, that's just plain weird.
Revenge is sought after and Shatner says Khan's name like he's passing a kidney stone.
KIRK: KHAN!!
What's this? Spock is sacrificing himself for the crew?
It appears this Vulcan wants out of this franchise.
Will he be sucked back by the fact that he's the most marketable character?
Stay tuned!
Same Star Trek time,
same Star Trek channel!
[Kirk screams "Khan!" over and over to the opening theme of Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan]
In continuing with Star Trek Month, we now take a look at Star Trek III: The Search for Spock.
Now, out of all the odd-numbered Star Trek movies,
this is probably the one that people say comes close to actually being pretty good.
But it still lacks the epic rivalry of II or the clever comedy of IV and so on, and so on.
Is it worth searching for? Let's find out!
This is Star Trek III.
So we open up with a recap of the last movie and we discover a rather effective way to save money on your opening credits:
just play your previous movie backwards.
Yeah. Who needs big special effects when you can simply push the rewind button on your last film?
We then cut to Kirk, who is still shaken by the loss of his Vulcan buddy.
KIRK: With most of our battle damage repaired, we're almost home.
Yet, I feel uneasy.
I wonder why.
CRITIC: Well, it's either the bean burrito that might be giving you indigestion,
or the fact that your BEST FRIEND JUST DIED.
I don't know, maybe it's the burrito!
KIRK: A hero's welcome, son, is that what you'd like?
Well God knows it should be.
CRITIC: We then cut to elsewhere in space, where a Klingon, played by Christopher Lloyd,
is gathering info on the Genesis project.
And apparently he buys his animals from Gozer's Pet Shop and Aquarium.
(Growl)
That thing is so cute. I'm gonna name him Balzac.
Hello Balzac! How you doin'?
And apparently he's so important to the story that he even gets his own scene.
(Speaking Klingon)
(Growls)
Yeah, wasn't that vitally important?
I couldn't see the story moving forward unless we knew that Balzac got fed.
It's the crux of the movie.
Boy, she's sure taking that whole
"gotta kill you" thing pretty well.
Not even a plea or an escape plan or a, "darn."
She just fully accepts it.
You know, if only more people were accepting of death.
[Ominous music]
Oh God, it's probably what we've been waiting for.
Okay, put it on screen.
[STATIC]
Hi, Critic!
SciFi Guy?
Yeah! Well, who'd you think it was going to be?
Oh, no one, I thought it was going to be Linkara...
Anyway, what's up?
Well I got that copy of Star Trek V that you wanted.
Oh that's right. I don't have a
copy of it because I only try to own good movies.
Yeah well, you know, being a sci-fi nerd, it's kind of required by law that I own everything Star Trek,
even the really bad stuff like the Christmas special. (Shudders)
There's a Christmas special?
Yeah. It's only legally viewable in Amsterdam, so uh,
You want the movie?
Oh, sure, upload it to my computer.
There ya go!
Let me tell you, your review of this I'm sure is going to be just as funny as mine.
You're planning on reviewing it, too?
Well, yeah, it is kind of my shtick.
Unfortunate.
I know what that means, and I'm totally cool with it!
I mean, I'd totally love to die on your behalf.
Indeed. Thrusters!
I think it's so awesome that you're gonna kill me like this! I mean, I can hardly wait.
Just, zap me into oblivion!
You will be remembered with honor.
FIRE!!
SCIFI GUY: Oh, wait wait wait. uh, before you do that, I am transferring my life savings into your bank account.
Hell, I'm not going to need it anymore.
Oh, well, thank you. That's very very kind of you.
FIRE!!
SCIFI GUY: Oh, also, I should just let you know that I had
all of my family members sign up to be your personal slaves after my passing.
Anything else I can do for you?
You know, wash your windows, shine your shoes?
Oh no, thank you, you've more than done enough,
SciFi Guy.
God, your understanding of the situation is unbelievable!
Well, I know it's for a good cause.
And, hey, just, good luck to you, man.
You too, my friend, you t...
FIRE!
Ha!
CRITIC: So, the Enterprise returns to the spacedock,
when Chekov suddenly discovers a human life form in Spock's quarters.
KIRK: I'm on my way.
CRITIC: Lord knows the security team doesn't go in first.
[Wimpy Voice] It's too scary!
They're only dressed for in case a 1940s football game breaks out!
But, it turns out, it's Dr. McCoy,
who is actually convinced that he, himself, is Spock.
MCCOY: Help me, Jim. Take me home.
KIRK: Bones, we are. We are home.
MCCOY: Then perhaps it's not too late.
CRITIC (as McCoy): You can still stop me from saying yes to Transformers 3.
KIRK: Uhura, get the medics down here!
KIRK: As developed by doctors Carol and David Marcus,
Genesis, simply put, is life from lifelessness.
KRUGE: Speak.
MALTZ: Impressive.
CRITIC: Oh my God, is that John Larroquette?!
It is! John Larroquette is a Klingon on Star Trek!
I, surprisingly, have little material for that.
John Larroquette as a Klingon...what the hell am I supposed to do with John Larroquette as a Klingon?
I mean, it's strange enough to notice,
but doesn't really lead its way to many comedic possibilities.
I'm kind of stuck.
Um...
Here's a tribble in "Night Court."
DAN FIELDING: Oh, I'm hurt. Oh, I'm offended.
What do you want, it's the best I can work with!
Meanwhile, Kirk is visited by Spock's father, who isn't too happy.
SAREK: Why did you leave him on Genesis?
Spock trusted you, and you denied him his future.
(As Kirk) Well, he wanted out of the franchise.
KIRK: He made no request of me.
He would not have spoken of it openly.
Bring that which he gave you, his katra, his living spirit.
KIRK: And how was I...
SAREK: Kirk.
I must have your thoughts.
CRITIC: So he does a mind meld with Kirk, but doesn't find the answers he's looking for.
[Star Trek: The Original Series theme]
(as Sarek) Oh God, look at all the green-skinned whores.
(as Sarek) Is this all your mind is filled with?
(as Kirk) The thoughts need a hobby.
SAREK: It is not here.
CRITIC: So if the mind of Spock isn't in Kirk, then where is it?
Well, how about in the mind of the guy
WHO THINKS HE'S SPOCK?!
But, no, that'd be too obvious.
We need clarification of this by going over to the nicely-shot-and-edited security camera footage.
SPOCK: Remember.
[DING!]
CRITIC: So, McCoy finds he's of two minds on everything,
but he figures a good old journey to the bar will shut up those voices in his head.
Oh yeah, fuck Call of Duty. THESE are the games of the future!
Take a look, it's like seeing what will come.
ALIEN: To your planet, welcome.
I here am new.
I name not important.
You seek I.
Message received.
CRITIC (as McCoy): Are you, hitting on me?
MCCOY: How much and how soon?
ALIEN: How much is where.
MCCOY: It's Genesis.
ALIEN: Genesis?!
CRITIC: You know, maybe you could say your lines a little easier if you stop imitating the voice of Stitch.
MCCOY: It's Genesis.
ALIEN: Genesis?!
(as Stitch) Genesis?! Ikkiba!
SECURITY OFFICER:
Can I offer you a ride home, Dr. McCoy?
Where's the logic in offering me a ride home, you idiot?
If I wanted a ride home would I be trying to charter a space flight?
(Growls)
CRITIC: Now I think he just farted.
You know, I think this guy's butt is where his mouth should be.
I'm not entirely sure.
SECURITY OFFICER: Federation security, sir. You're gonna get a nice long rest, doctor.
CRITIC: But Kirk and Sulu go to break him out, as they try to get into the Genesis...
ALIEN: Genesis?!
CRITIC: ...planet,
which has just become forbidden.
(Guard yawns)
SULU: Keeping you busy?
Don't get smart, Tiny.
Don't call me Tiny.
CRITIC (as Sulu): Anytime you want to use the word "tiny" just use the word "Takei" instead.
KIRK: The Kobayashi Maru has set sail for the promised land.
CRITIC: So a good chunk of the gang steal the Enterprise with Starfleet not far behind.
CHEKOV: Commander, Starfleet on emergency channel. He orders you to surrender this wessel.
CRITIC (as Kirk): Well I have no idea what a "wessel" is, so I can't surrender it.
STYLES: Kirk, if you do this you'll never sit in the captain's chair again.
Well technically his contract has him for three more movies, so that's very unlikely.
STYLES: Prepare for warp speed, standby transwarp drive.
[Over-the-top cartoony vehicle sound effect]
[WAH WAH WAH WAAAAAH!]
SCOTTY: Souvenirs, from one surgeon to another. I took them out of her main transwarp computer drive.
Ah, yes, and the over-the-top cartoony vehicle sound effect?
(as Scotty) Well that was just for laughs.
(Normal voice) We then cut to the Genesis...
ALIEN: Genesis?!
...planet.
As Kirk's son David and...not...Kirstie Alley
look over their Commodore 64 graphics and notice that a life form is down there.
So, they head on down to check it out.
ELMER FUDD: Wabbit twacks!
After traveling for a while they finally come across the life form -
which makes no sense, wouldn't they just beam to its exact location -
and they see that the life form is in fact a younger version of Spock,
with no memories and no means of speech.
Kind of like Courtney Love after a few drinks.
But then the evil Klingons come in to ruin the day.
(Speaking Klingon)
(as Kruge) Now who are we gonna eat?!
TORG: If it's prisoners you want, there are life signs on the planet, perhaps the very scientists you seek.
CRITIC: So the Klingons beam themselves down to the planet where the others are.
Several miles away from where the others are.
You know, the logic behind teleporters doesn't make much sense.
And here's a fun little development:
it turns out Spock is going through pon farr,
which Star Trek history suggests that Spock has to mate with something in order to survive.
GEORGE TAKEI: Ohhh myyyy.
CRITIC: Well, this can only mean one sizzling conclusion:
[70's porn music]
Oh yeah. Time to do the Spock-er.
[70's porn music continues]
Oh yeah, rub those fingers, caress those thumbnails! Mmm...
Oh yeah, touch those knuckles! Rub them all over!
[70's porn music continues]
Now rub the inside of her wrist and gently work your way around to...
[porn music stops]
y-you know, this isn't very sexy.
I mean, is this really all we see?
This is Star Trek! We've seen Kirk make out with God knows how many ladies,
and yet for Spock we get sort of
this half-assed E.T. sex?!
I'm sorry, I thought we'd get something more steamy!
Uh, Spock, when a pretty lady asks you to finger her, this isn't what she means.
(Speaking Klingon)
SAAVIK: Spock!
CRITIC: But the Klingon cockblockers come in and ruin the...
oh let's face it, they didn't ruin anything.
KRUGE: I've come a long way for the power of Genesis...
ALIEN: Genesis?!
KRUGE: ...and what do I find?
A weakling human,
a Vulcan boy,
and a woman.
(as Kruge) Sounds like the beginning of a joke at a sci-fi con.
TORG: Federation starship approaching.
KRUGE: Bring me up.
So Lloyd goes back up to his ship and gets ready for battle.
KIRK: That distortion, see it?
SULU: Yes, sir. It's getting larger as we close in.
(Speaking Klingon)
CRITIC: Ever notice, by the way, that all his Klingon pronunciation is very similar to a cat puking up?
(Critic making cat puking sounds)
CHEKOV: Shields non-responsive.
KIRK: Scotty?
SCOTTY: The automation system's overloaded. I didn't expect to take us into combat, ya know.
CRITIC: Oh yeah, because STEALING A STARSHIP and being hunted down by the entire Federation
would EVER put you in a situation where you need to defend yourself.
So the Klingons fire at them,
they fire at the Klingons,
both are unable to use their weapons, and they find themselves at a stalemate.
And this leads to probably one of the most senseless, disturbing,
yet emotional death scenes that has ever come out of any Star Trek film.
BALZAC!!
NOOOOO!!
KIRK: Precautionary, Mr. Chekov.
Screenwriting bastards, you killed my Balzac.
Oh!
Screenwriting bastards, you killed my Balzac!
You...
murdered and maimed a totally pointless character!
Oh!
Oh and Kirk's son gets killed as a means to force him to surrender,
it's very tragic but,
you screenwriting BASTARDS, you killed my Balzac!
YOU KILLED MY BALZAC!
Oh!
Nobody told me this was gonna be like Marley & Me in space!
I'm sorry, I...
I need a minute to recover from this.
Here's some products whoring themselves out for your pleasure.
(Whispering) Screenwriting bastards, you killed my Balzac.
Oh my Balzac!
Ok.
I think I'm fi...I think I've recovered.
So, as you can imagine, nothing can top the...
dramatic explosion that was...
the death of dear Balzac.
They've reached the height of dramatic tension, people. There's no way they're gonna top it.
Best we get is the blowing up of the starship Enterprise as soon as the Klingons get on board.
And the heroes watch from the planet. Ooh!
BUT WILL IT BRING BACK BALZAC?!
Actually, the blowing up of the Enterprise is pretty epic.
And they give it a lot of weight, too.
I especially like the buildup when Lloyd puts together what the self-destruct countdown means.
TORG: The ship appears to be deserted.
KRUGE: How can that be?
They're hiding.
But the bridge seems to be run by computer.
Let me hear it.
COMPUTER: Nine...
eight...
seven...
[POP]
six...
[BOOM!]
five...
KRUGE: GET OUT!
four...
GET OUT OF THERE!!
three...
two...
KIRK: My God, Bones.
What have I done?
MCCOY: What you had to do.
What you always do.
Turn death into a fighting chance to live.
You could sum up his whole career with that line.
So they find Spock and not-Kirstie Alley and try to save them.
However, they're still without a ship, and the planet's about to blow.
So, he makes a deal with Lloyd.
KIRK: I have what you want.
I have the secret of Genesis.
ALIEN: Genesis?!
You're gonna have to bring us up there to get it.
CRITIC (as Kruge): Bite my pointy AquaTread tire head.
KRUGE: Drop all weapons!
(Speaking Klingon)
CRITIC: So he beams most of the team aboard, but leaves himself, Kirk, and Spock on the planet.
KIRK: You fool, look around you!
The planet's destroying itself!
KRUGE: Yes, exhilarating, isn't it?
If we don't help each other, we'll die here.
Perfect.
Then that's the way it shall be.
CRITIC (as Kruge): Oop. Ok. Sorry, I wasn't meaning to attack you, but then the ground raised up, and,
well, I just decided to own it.
(Normal voice) Uh, yeah.
I think all the straps on Shatner's girdle would break if he pulled that stunt off.
Ooh, all four of his balls!
DOC BROWN (high pitched): 1.21 jigawatts!
(Screams)
CRITIC: So he hangs him off a cliff, and finally does him in.
KIRK: I...
have HAD...
enough of YOU!
(Screams)
CHARLIE WILCOX: I was frozen t...
CRITIC: They take control of the Klingon ship and take Spock home to the planet of Vulcan.
There, on a Siegfried & Roy stage,
they talk about making the transition from McCoy's mind back into Spock's.
T'LAR: What you seek has not been done since ages past,
and then, only in legend.
Your request is not logical.
SAREK: Forgive me, T'Lar.
My logic...
is uncertain...
where my son is concerned.
CRITIC: Well, I guess the all-logic-based society says logic only holds weight SOME of the time,
and they decide to do the transition.
Spock wakes up ok and walks around in a robe from a (as Kirk, mockingly) spaaaa.
SPOCK: I have been...
and ever shall be...
your friend.
KIRK: Yes.
The ship...
out of danger?
You saved the ship.
I blew it up later, but, eh.
SPOCK: Jim.
Your name...is Jim.
CRITIC: So Spock gets his memory back,
Takei cops a feel,
and we're not-so-subtly told the adventure continues.
For the needs of the franchise outweigh the needs of not kicking a dead horse.
So that's Star Trek III: The Search for Spock.
And honestly?
I don't think it's that bad.
I mean, ok, it's not as good as some of the others,
and it does drag at times, but,
it's still got some big death scenes,
some strong moments,
and it does feel very operatic at times.
I think the major thing missing is that,
it needed a villain along the lines of Khan to really complete it, and
even though Lloyd is a lot of fun,
and he's a pretty good bad guy,
the character is just sort of a one-note nut.
I think a really strong rivalry would've made it a lot more epic.
Overall, though, I think it's still pretty good.
I can see how others may find it boring, but
I think the strong stuff still stands out.
It's not the best, but it's got enough good moments.
And just as the adventure continues, so does Star Trek Month.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic.
I remember it, so you don't have to.
[Theme from Star Trek II]
ALIEN: Genesis?!